Okay.
And we're live. What's up Yo, dude,
you're on a rollercoaster ride.
What is it like to be the champ?
What's the feeling like this is
fresh for you? Oh, well first of all,
I just want to say, man, it's such an
honor to be here. Um, the honor is mine.
I never, I'm gonna I'm
gonna be honest. Um, um,
my thing is I'm just going to
be 100% and totally transparent.
I was never,
I never really watched the show.
I never really kind of heard of this show.
Of course I heard of you and all the
things you do. I'm like, Oh yeah,
it's fear factor guy and all,
but I never really heard of this show
until like after like a fight or two in
the UFC and people are like
tagging me and shit. Like,
Yo Joe Rogan's talking by Joe.
Ranga talked about you in pocket.
I'm like fucking podcast. Cause I'd
never listened to podcasts at the time.
I was like, oof, what are you talking
about? Until I finally started listening,
I'm like, oh, this dude is for real.
This dude got some, some, some pool.
You've got some people watching this shit.
Random people would tag me.
Oh Joel was talking about you today
on the podcast. I'm like, Oh man,
this guy's for real. And then every
time after that that I see you,
I'm like sub Gel.
Yeah we've been talking about
you for a long time man.
We were just with your friend out there.
We're watching a video of us talking
about you back when you were ranked number
12 and I was saying I think you can
fight for the title right now. Yeah man.
That um,
and I I like to attest it to,
I think because I went back once
I started kind of researching you,
I like to go back and do a little research
and I'm like fucking Joe's been with
this,
this sport for the beginning.
Like you were in the back with hair
[inaudible] the hair freaking interview in
the guys yet during the tournament that
we're finding multiple fights and night
and you were interviewing those guys
and I was like damn. Even back there,
Joe had skills. Joel was the
beast interview in these guys.
There was no shaking behind it.
Cause I, you know one thing about me,
I've gotten into comp and commentating
and things like that now and I'm like
Dang Joe, he didn't seem nervous. You
would just like a freaking natural at it.
And the sport was just growing
at that time. I was like,
there was nobody watching back then.
It wasn't as much pressure, you know,
it wasn't like coming into it today.
Yeah. Espn paper view, all that deal.
It would be a lot of pressure. But
back then it was just fun. Yeah it was.
It was weird man.
The first one I did was in Dothan,
Alabama and this weird like it was,
I don't know if it was a high
school gym or some small auditorium,
tiny little place. It was
very weird. They have a,
you made it look like a freaking certain
little walk in the park. I mean it was,
I was like damn chosen good at the
gentleman doing this shit for a wow. Well,
it's a, it's an interesting
thing to see, you know,
to see it progress from 1997
to where it's out of 2019.
The biggest difference is not just,
uh,
the amount of eyes at accounts in amount
of people that are paying attention to
the real difference is the level
of athlete. It's a, it's a giant,
giant leap.
Like in no other sport,
I don't think there's another sport
from 1993 to 2019 where the athletes are
almost, it's almost unrecognizable. How
much better the fighters are as Lilly,
you know, it's now back in
the day it was like, okay,
you finished your college career,
you finished all this,
you've got to the height of whatever
you know, sport you could be,
let's start fighting.
And so guys were coming in at 28,
27 starting to learn the tricks.
Now you've got freaking
10 year old kids sparring.
There's all these crazy videos like little
bitty kids fighting in like Russia or
other places. Like they're full on
MMA fighting. Yeah, totally distinct.
That whole promotion. I'm like, man,
by the time these guys get to 1617,
they're going to be killers.
Have,
if you go back and watch like a boxing
match from like 93 a by a world champion
boxer like Marvin Hagler,
perfect example,
Marvin Hagler from the 80s
could absolutely hang with
w middleweights like he's,
he would fit right in with world
champions today. Absolutely.
But a UFC champ from 93 mean ah,
it's just not the same.
It's not by any stretch. It's, it is such
a, back then it was like a, it was wild.
It was crazy. But nobody
had endurance. And you know,
there was a few guys that had some
skill and certainly our v Orlando VA or
hoists Gracie, there was guys are
really good at their individual arts,
but there was no real
complete fighters yet. Yeah.
You got the transition because it was,
everyone came in with their special
skills and that was, that was a big thing.
I think UFC even sold that as, oh yeah,
you got the wrestler firing, the calm,
the Combo, the sambal guy
and the Jujitsu guy. And, uh,
so that was the thing.
Everyone came in with their one skill
and they put it to the test to see what
you still watch better. It's
freaking crazy. Joe. My first fight,
first time I ever watched a UFC fight,
I was visiting John Jones
in college freshman year.
This was our, our, our
freshman year to freshman year.
I was visiting him cause I went to uh,
a small school unit when
William Penn University,
which was about two hours away from him.
He was at Iowa Central in Fort Dodge,
Iowa. So I went to go spend my fall break
a whole week with him just hanging out
because we had met the previous year
in high school and just, you know,
it's two brothers and wrestling. It was
like, hey two brothers, what's up man?
Where you go, let's go like shares, like
I'll be, I was like show me too as well.
We kept in touch and I want
them to hang out with him.
And during that week it was a fight
on someone, like a friend of the team,
something like that invited us to
come to his house and watch it.
And we went over there to watch the
fights. I had never really heard of it.
I never really cared.
I was just at freshman just trying to
hang out with John and Paul uses around,
this was 2005 to I think,
yeah,
2005 so it was like first season
of the ultimate fighter. Yeah,
2005 so we go on,
I think it might've been Randy couture
or somewhat John just reminded,
but I forgot who was fighting and we
went to the House party and watched it.
I really didn't really remember the
fight cause I didn't really care.
I never paid attention to it.
I never thought I would ever do something
like that. So I just watched it.
And then I remember the guy saying,
hey man, you guys can do this.
Why don't you guys try this?
And I was,
I mean John kind of looked
at each other like hell no.
And the way we go and do that shit. You
know, wrestling is controlled. You know,
there's rules, you know, certain
things you can or can't do.
There's no way we're doing that. So we
kind of laughed it off and left that day.
Never knew that I freaking,
years later I'd be doing this.